okay why don't we go ahead and get
started point we've we've been having
some big audiences this is great so this
is our Thursday conference most of you
are regular attendees and just we use
the microphone mainly because we stream
this wakes and we not only stream it but
also record it which is why when you ask
a question which we encourage you to do
we ask that you hold down the button on
the microphone not not so much that
people in the room can hear it but so
that people who are listening in and
there are people who listening in and
for those of you out there many of you
probably know if you want to ask a
question you just tweet with the hashtag
demise comp DMIC e conf and that usually
someone monitors the twitter feed and i
can actually attest that this system
works well week ago today I was a week
ago it was actually friday morning where
I was in Singapore I listened to Tim's
talk at least until the microphone
battery went out and then I couldn't get
I disconnected because I thought that
was a problem and I couldn't reconnect
but I got to hear most of his talk and I
was actually going to tweet a question
but I didn't get a chance to what one
before I introduce Aaron I just want one
other thing especially since a lot of
you are here I just want to give you a
save the date I think I've mentioned
this before but on March seventeenth
many of you know Kevin Johnson dr. Kevin
Johnson who is the chair of informatics
at Vanderbilt was actually produced a
movie a documentary movie on health
information exchange and will be coming
to visit ohs you will probably do one of
these noon talk so that will probably
have it in a bigger room and then in the
evening will actually show this movie
and then we're actually going to invite
some people from around Oregon to kind
of talk about health information
exchange efforts going on so we'll
hopefully be an interesting day and I
hope we can get a good turnout to show
Kevin how enthusiastic are
students are for when the chair from
Vanderbilt comes and of course
Vanderbilt just another domino has
fallen in the epic universe has chosen
to replace its homegrown system with
epic but anyways but we're here to here
Aaron today so I don't want to take away
from his time I will briefly introduce
Aaron since most of you know him and I
don't need a paper this time because I
know his history so well Aaron did his
undergraduate work at the University of
Michigan Electrical Engineering went to
medical school in boston decided that he
didn't want to follow the patient care
path and ended up in the software
industry initially in boston and then
landed at intel and then about i don't
know about 12 years ago decided he kind
of wanted to gravitate back towards
medicine and he knew a mutual friend of
ours and he came to my office and i
talked him into doing the NLM fellowship
which he did really well and then I
talked him into joining our faculty
which he's done really well and he's had
a lot of success in the traditional
academic sense in terms of publications
grants and contributions to science and
teaching but really in the last few
years has focused on what we call the
informatics discovery lab and which i
think is a very important initiative in
the department in terms of looking
beyond our kind of traditional things we
do academically like write papers and
teach students which is very important
but also kind of reaching out and
disseminating informatics not only
knowledge but actual activity and so the
IDL has been the main conduit for that
so I will so Aaron periodically gives a
talk on kind of an update on the IDL
there's opportunities for faculty and
students and others to work on projects
so i will turn it over to Aaron thanks
well you could give this talk though
that was they talk in a nutshell right
there so so why are we here again well
some thank you all for coming by the way
some people say you're all here for the
pizza but you know
maybe you're here for the pizza and to
hear about the idea which is great some
of you have heard parts of this talk
last year because i did a state of the
idea last year and so there'll be some
new stuff for you for people who are new
and haven't heard this before there will
be some background in review so many of
you are probably asking some of these
questions the new people are you know
what's the IDL and why do we have an IDL
and I'll answer some of that what is the
IDL been doing lately that for people
that already know the first to just be
an update so you know what what's going
on and lastly how can i get an involved
with the idea which is kind of an
ongoing question for everybody so what's
the ideal as bill said as an initiative
of the department it's not separate from
the department it's not an institute
it's not a different thing it's an
initiative an initiative is really you
know kind of a label to give us
structure and a team to do to focus on
something and what we wanted to focus on
is really informatics collaborations and
and sort of what we call non-traditional
collaborations what i mean by
non-traditional is is collaborations
with people that academic informations
traditionally didn't collaborate with so
what's non-traditional is is our outlook
not the people were collaborating with
that non-traditional would mean other
clinical departments commercial
institutions you know could be
government any of that kind of thing
different than for example collaborating
on a grant where you've got
co-investigators from a number of
different institutions be mice you know
and there's nothing wrong with that
right d mice but Themis already did that
well they didn't need a special
initiative to focus on this so we're
outwardly oriented the agenda is to get
academic informatics into the real world
we want we don't want to just stop at
publishing articles we have this really
good idea you know informatics and d
mice in particular is very good at doing
evaluation you know we get this good
idea we implement the alpha version of
it we do an evaluation we publish a
paper and then we go on to the next
thing so we don't want to do that we
want
actually deploy that in the real world
now publishing is also a very good thing
to do and I'll come back to this point a
few times we also have to publish all
this stuff in fact the idea is to get
some synergy between the real world
applications and the publishing you know
in academia in to some extent in the in
the real world as well you know
publishing and giving talks like this
that's how you actually get recognition
and credit and acknowledgement for the
stuff that you did I think that you know
I often tell my students that if you
don't publish it's like you never did it
and I think that's true in academia it's
not necessarily so much true in
operations there's still a lot of value
in doing something even if you don't
publish it in operations we can impact
health care we can impact the quality of
life of patients in that way but even so
much better to publish it get it out
there get other people to see and build
off of your ideas right so even more
value that way so who's the idea well
Deb and I are quote unquote the leaders
you know I'm the director of the IDL
that Deb is the program manager we have
guidance from a lot of faculty at the
University I won't read all the list of
ideal advisors this has gone through
kind of some transitions over the last
couple of years we officially have an
advisory board but over the last year
it's been sort of difficult I think take
best advantage of that our individual
projects in the ID I'll have leadership
and advisory boards and guidance and
I'll talk about specific projects with
the two nights the night cancer and the
night cardiovascular and we have
advisory boards for those but the
overall idea we have more like advisors
and working out how best to use those
effectively as something I think that
we're going to be doing in some of the
strategic planning that we're doing for
next year as ongoing other faculty staff
and students lots of people are working
on IDL project and have been involved in
some way I won't read the whole names
but lots of people either are you know
substantial time full time part time
accessory time on IDL project
and so it's really a large group of
people I think I said this last year you
know there's a picture of the little
department web page snapshots really you
know because it's an initiative and the
department everybody's welcome right
it's not like a fixed thing where
there's a boundary a hard boundary
around the IDL and you're either in or
out people will move in and out based on
what projects they're working on based
on what they're interested in what the
needs are and what their skills are etc
etc so everyone is welcome to
participate as there's a good fit and it
aligns with those objectives that we
talked about on the prior slide so why
do we have an idea well originally you
know and I don't have the slide in here
anymore I talked about a lot of
collaboration with industry and how
academia and industry can work together
and I think that's still true there are
some some challenges to that that we
found that I'll talk about briefly but
even more true is that there's a great
lead for informatics just within the
healthcare system even even just within
ohsu and let's say oh it's issue and
their partners as ohsu becomes kind of a
health health system with taking on risk
and managing risk and insurance system
and everything else as it's growing I
mean of our guys have heard about the
deals and arrangements with with moda
and with salem health and all these
things that have happened during the
last year that that just ups the need I
think for deep informatics in the
healthcare system so there's really a
great need for this a great opportunity
and to really realize the value to
health and improving the quality value
and health of you know our population I
think informatics in general and the
better and more active use of
information as an essential thing in
that so there's just you know it's it's
I still got the explosion slide but it's
a different explosion this is the
explosion of the need to use informatics
and data wisely in the improvement of
our
system so what's needed I'm going to
I've listed a number of different things
here but I'm going to actually go in a
different order so you know the bulleted
list you know don't imply any kind of
ranking the number one thing really is
delivering value to the customer so
who's who's the customer right i mean
one thing that i found is you know
contrasting say my intel engineering
experience with my academic experience
is that you know academic value has a
set of things that are important in a
priority of those things and health care
delivery systems have a different set of
value and priority of those things and
if you're doing work in the real world
you really have to deliver that value to
the customer now that said I think that
there's a lot of overlap between the
lists of those two groups and there's a
lot of potential for synergy but I think
the priorities in the order are somewhat
different and you need to be sensitive
to that thing in order to in order to
succeed and there's lots of little
details with that you know differing
timing and timelines when people need
things different kinds of arrangements
and contracts that don't look anything
like grant proposals and we've had to be
creative with the University and the
department management to figure out how
to do some of these things different
kinds of project management and
reporting probably you know much more
like agile project management and or
more formal commercial project
management than sometimes grant project
management intellectual property
concerns if you're working with
companies these can be really
complicated time-consuming issues number
of faculty who are working on some of
these things we're probably be nodding
their head around this and not so much
when we're talking about dealing with
internal health system customers which
is good because it takes out that whole
kind of complexity there so you know all
of these things um wrap around this idea
of what's a value to the customer and
how you figure that out you know what
are who is the customer what are their
goals what are their
how can we achieve those things that
whole process it's not just about you
know intellectual curiosity and
scholarship some of it's about that but
that's not the top thing so how do we
develop competencies in that and that's
one of the things that the IDL has been
working on and I think gaining you know
improved skills at doing and this this
comes down from from you know smaller
two big things you know big big things
like being aware of the intellectual
property issues and how to work with
tech transfer and what's going to be a
huge time sink and what's going to work
well and hot assign licensing agreements
and do that in an effective manner with
different companies that we have
collaborations and and whatnot and to
you know relatively simple things like
you know that change management tracking
for projects and things like that and
having a place to store the accumulated
knowledge and experience of what the
project is so it's searchable and all
that you know we're in fermentation so
we should use informatics tools for our
own information as well right anybody's
been here last year has seen this slide
right what are the aims of the IDL and
the nice thing about this and maybe one
of the big reasons why I kept this slide
in here is because I think all these
things are true and it hasn't really
changed right the I the aims are to make
the most of the opportunities
established long-term partnerships to
proly rigorous informatics into the wild
enhance the scope of the education and
training in our program lead a
collaborative entrepreneurial culture
diversify funding sources i should also
say in here provide informatics
leadership to the University and the
community that hasn't changed so that
that's been nice that you know after I
don't know what is it Deb it's like
three years of the IDL now this is still
lines up with early what we see our
aims are so this is the new part what do
we been doing over the last year well
lots of stuff within ohsu we've gotten
our cardiovascular institute partnership
that i'll talk about we've done a couple
of partnerships with the knight Cancer
Institute including a text Manning
bake-off and a more text mining oriented
service corps the beginning is of a
service core development and and these
things with the asterisk I have slides
on and i'll talk more about the data
science initiative if you've probably
heard there's a big data science
initiative going on at the university to
plan you know what does it mean to do
data science at ohsu what's our strategy
really at an institutional level and
we've had a lot of input and been part
of that process which is still ongoing
beyond ohsu we've continued and enhanced
and are looking to expand our epic
partnership in a number of directions we
have a new imo partnership that will
that I'll talk about really briefly
again gets into those licensing issues
and teams from ohsu led by the
quote-unquote sponsored by the IDL and
led in part by Deb Woodcock does the
program manager has 12 success 22
sequential thank you Amy a design
challenges which is pretty cool I think
so let's talk about the night
cardiovascular institute partnership it
really has to do with enhancing the
quality of care and informing workflow
redesign with analytics right how does
the night cardiovascular institute
become a top ten cardiovascular center
in the in the country in the world how
do we do that and the 11 approach and 11
essential ingredient in this approach is
using data right we need to know how
we're doing and we also need to know if
changes we put in place make things any
better or not and if they don't we need
to come up with different ideas to make
things better and then see if those
actually
are reflected in the data so you know
this is you know this is you know
process improvement and data different
decision-making coming to madison
finally and this is doing it in a real
world so what we've been doing is
creating a monitoring system that allows
you to do this and we started with the
sort of initial project centre done and
I think I'm jumping ahead of slide
sitting on a heart failure and the
American College of Cardiology measures
that are relating to heart failure is an
initial set these all go through a whole
pipeline and are computed on a regular
basis and then they're visualized with
tableau tableau is a tool for
visualizing data and you can produce
interactive graphics and things like
that where you can drill down and
explore and you can also just produce
nice-looking reports that turn into a
PDF that can be mailed to the users on a
regular basis and archived and referred
back to and all that kind of thing very
much a team driven agile process we're
iterating and improving and refining as
we go there's a huge partnership
component to this which is that which is
that you know there's sort of the
informatics technical aspect and there's
the the workflow clinical knowledge best
practices what do we really do at ohsu
what data do we capture how do we use
epic and how do we fit all that together
to produce a meaningful system with
meaningful results and that that that
collaboration and that interactivity is
really essential you know I always an
often say that you know it's easy to
write some SQL and produce some numbers
but without any context and without any
understanding of the of the limitations
and environmental aspect of those
numbers they probably don't mean
anything and likely nobody's gonna
believe them anyway so that gets into
validation right one of the things I
think that we as a department are very
good at and we've brought into the IDL
is this idea of validating things right
we don't just produce numbers we don't
just build systems and run them out but
we actually do
nificant amount of validation this is a
slide I think Nicole made but it's still
documents sort of our process for
creating measures and a very important
part about this is is is the actual
manual validation you know much like you
this is where we can bring in some of
the academic rigor right much like a
research study we actually sample the
data from the measures and evaluate by
manually by doing a pretty thorough
chart review how accurate the measures
are it turns out that what you can do
with an automated system is is limited
by the data that's in the system whether
that's structured or unstructured data
and you have to make interpretations of
what gets done and what that data means
and how it applies to the different
measures and by doing validation you can
tell what the limitations of that
approach are and if they have some
significant impact on the measures that
you're calculating or not we have this
discussion yesterday in our team meeting
if the if the approximations your you're
making are sort of randomly and evenly
distributed they often look like they're
not making a big difference in the
measures in the measures you're
calculating the numbers are still
accurate as compared to the manual
review if they're biased in some way
then that's going to be a problem and
you're going to have to deal with that
but the way you're going to determine
that the way they're going to attack
that again is with the manual review go
ahead push the button to work in from an
informatics perspective it seems sort of
self evident that we would always do
this in health care and yet having been
on meaningful use implementation
projects and now actually looking at the
end of Meaningful Use announced this
week much of what we've done in health
care around operate addicts does not
take this type of rigorous approach
we've implemented EHRs we pull data out
we report the data without a validation
step and so it's great that we're now
looking in the next decade of
operational informatics sister doing
this yeah thank you I mean that it's the
validation again is it
necessary but not you know not
sufficient all by itself but it's
totally necessary because without doing
that you don't really know what the
numbers mean the numbers may be the
reflection of what you intended to
measure they might be measuring
something different like half the
providers are using this tool to
calculate the numbers and fill it out
and the other half aren't so it's it's a
what it really tells you in that case is
not is not necessarily that the patients
are not receiving appropriate care but
it's telling you that you've got
inconsistency in your workflow in your
practice and and you might want to look
at shoring up that consistency so no
matter who they see in your group they
get treated and documented in the same
way that's a that's a workflow in a care
management and practice decision but
without that inside of the data and the
validation you're just working in the
dark validation is actually a complex
business and we've developed some some
graphics and visualization to try to
dive into this and this is some work
actually the Nicole who is coming back
from maternity leave soon yay developed
and I wanted to show this to you just to
give you a flavor of this and this is
where I think some of the academic
operational aspects of this really come
to really show themselves because this
is something we needed to develop to get
our heads around the data but I also
think that it's something we need to
write up and publish and present so what
this is is so when you're doing these
measures right you know like three
sentences on clinical quality measures
when you're doing these measures you're
usually computing a ratio and there's a
numerator and the denominator and let's
say it's a patient level measure so
there's some number of patients in the
denominator and there's some number of
patients in the numerator and the ratio
is quote unquote how good you're doing
and the measures if they're ACC measures
are defined by an official body although
measures I got I want to say is
could be defined by ourselves and the
practice based on what our goals are and
what we think is an appropriate way to
measure what our goals are they don't
have to be you know come designed by
some committee somewhere else but for
the purposes of the heart failure
measures and certainly this one which
happens to be the ACC measure one left
ventricular ejection fraction
measurement they're there they're
predefined you have to interpret them
they're defined like text you read them
and interpret them and apply them to
their day to your data and you've got
essentially something that defines a set
operation for numerators and set
operation for denominators and then the
ratio of the numbers in those sets gives
you your quality measure and you want to
keep computing this on a regular basis
and you know so you have this over time
and you can graph it over time and you
can look at trends and all that kind of
stuff but when you do the validation
you've got lots of sources of variation
in error right because you've got an
automated system which is counting up
the numerator patients you've got an
automated system which is counting up
the denominator patients and you've got
the automated system calculating the
ratio and all that well when you do the
validation you gotta validate the
numerator you got to validate the
denominator so and you got to validate
the measure right so there's all those
anyway comparisons and that's what this
slide actually shows if you look at the
just looking at the top row and I think
fisa probably does a much better job
explaining us than than I do so correct
me if I get anything wrong the if you
look at the top row well let me give you
a little background the numerator
numbers are in red and the size of the
circle sort of reflects the size of the
number sorry the denominator is red i
was trying i met the denominator the
denominator is rad it says right there
and the size is the size of the circle
and the numerator is orange and again at
the size of the circle and then the
overlap shows the intersection and so
for example for this heart failure
measure
there's a certain rad amount and on this
side is the automated measure and on
this side is the manual validation and
what you'll see is that the the numerous
art the denominator match this shows the
relative denominator match between the
automated system and the and Emanuel
chart review very very high overlap
these circles there's just a little a
little difference here so we're getting
all the right patients in the numerator
in the denominator check me on this the
numerator on the other hand there is
some difference right there's some
difference between what we're getting in
the automated system which is the inner
circle and what the manual chart review
shows in the in the outer circle and
that leads to this difference in the in
the performance estimate which is the
overlap of those circles the automated
systems on the left and the manual chart
review is is on the right and then the
intersection basically shows the
difference in the actual ratio in the
quality measure so you know that this is
this is the amount of the automated
system the ratio of the automated system
and this is the measure of the of the
manual chart review and what this shows
is we're doing a good job of the of the
denominator but we're missing patients
on the numerator right these patients in
this strip our patients that have been
appropriately cared for but we're
missing them in the automated system and
what this basically winds up with is is
is a limitation in our data collection
where the recording of the measuring of
the lvef either happened outside ohsu so
it doesn't exist in any structured field
and epic it might be in a PDF of an
outside report or something or it might
be in a patient note and uh you know the
issue then the opportunity is well is
that important and what do you want to
do about it do we want to enter that in
a structured feel when it comes from an
outside place do we want to change
something else in our workflow and then
there's then you can have the
conversation about well whose
responsibility is to do that when does
it get done all that kind of stuff you
want to make a comment
okay but you look like you wanted to say
something so so Greg is actually our
sponsor and then project lead or
customer lead from kc b eyes thanks for
coming so there's and and you know we've
got one of these for every one of the
measures and every one of them has
different insight that you can glean
from from looking at the picture I don't
have it here right now but there are
some measures where there's some
variation in terms of the numerators and
the denominators where they're they
don't overlap exactly completely but
when you actually do the intersection
the overall calculation is very close to
what the manual chart review is because
they kind of cancel out because they're
randomly distribute so that's all nice
and that's good informatics and
validation so we believe the numbers and
we can you know show the customers that
validation so that they believe us and
then realize that the system's working
as intended and we understand what it
does but in the end we produce a report
and this is just a screenshot of the
first page of the report that basically
shows each of the measures organized by
organized by the overall Casey VI
Institute as well as the individual
specialty groups that they wanted to
break it out and there's lots of
different ways to slice and dice the
data this is just one way that we
decided would be generally useful and I
was just bringing out two different
lines that are sort of zoomed out from
the report HTC measure 6 and 7 which are
basically a sand beta-blocker therapy
for patients that have congestive heart
failure this is the n the number of
patients in the denominator and this is
the actual quality measure and where
they are all with the automated system
all running on a regular basis
generating the report every week right
now we're not just automatically
generating an important sending it out
it's actually being looked at by
somebody before just to make sure that
there's nothing wrong with it but but
it's it's largely automated
okay so any questions about night
cardiovascular I can answer at the end
hopefully I'll leave some time for
questions we also have a partnership
with the knight Cancer Institute this
started with over a year and a half ago
the knight Cancer Institute higher duty
bar Cal who is IT strategist for the
night and we've been having
conversations over the years about you
know where the IT strategy is going and
Judy's ideas and she came up with this
idea for translational research hub and
I'm not going to get into a lot of
detail about this but the idea is to
have an easy place for the night cancer
investigators to go to get integrated
data to do the research simple idea
right not so easy to execute but simple
idea part of that is and I really should
have like one of her diagrams or
something in here part of that is the
idea that a lot of information is locked
up in the text in the pathology reports
and clinical notes and things like that
and that that automated text processing
of those reports should be a feed into
the translational research hub right so
to do that we need to have some sort of
you know not just academic capability
but core facility for doing that
automated text extraction so Judy comes
from industry most recently I think was
at IBM and I remember exactly what level
do you know pretty high level high level
management and you know we looked at
what it would take versus x versus build
and decided that even it was going to be
a lot of work just to build up this
capability we're going to buy a
technology that we were going to build
this capability on top of there are many
vendors in this space believe it or not
and the IDL helped and organize and run
essentially a vendor bake-off using
anonymized ohsu data and giving it to
these different vendors
with a week and saying here's the kind
of stuff we're interested in here's the
medical concepts extract out the best
that you can and give it back to us in a
week and we didn't want to give them
more than a week because we didn't want
to give them an inordinate amount of
time we didn't want to give them time
where they thought that they could
manually add it the results or anything
like that it was enough work that you
know they could do some system building
and then apply their system in a week
and then send us back the results then
we did the manual review and assess the
different vendors and it turned out that
one vendor was much much better than
everyone else basically one vendor was
prepared and the other vendors were not
so prepared and that was lingua maddox
which is an English company that also
has offices in the US and they have a
product called I to e which is basically
and Stephen woo who's in the audience
can comment on this sort of a
commercialized embodiment of your best
and standard sort of practices for
pattern matching in automated text
processing but it's a commercially
supported project right so that means
that you get upgrades and they may
maintain it and they add terminologies
to it and all that kind of good stuff so
that's how we got to where we are now
what we're doing now is building up a
core capability for text extraction
using that language system there are a
number of pilot projects that we're
doing to demonstrate the value and also
learn how best to use the system several
different clinical trials where we'll be
extracting out potential patients that
meet the basic criteria for the clinical
trials and then using that in to inform
the trial recruiters to contact patients
if they so choose this actually has some
nice duck tales in with what Tim talked
about last week sending out automated my
chart emails and things like that
offering patients the opportunity to
participate in the clinical trial which
i think is probably a good next step bio
library ohsu has a bio library with
with a with a library of biological
samples that have been annotated by a
lot of different genomic and other tests
it will increase value to that bio
library to have those samples annotated
with things from the EHR and so there's
a pilot project going on to actually
extract those things from path reports
and notes in order to improve the
annotation right now they do the
annotation but they're doing it manually
by going through the chart and clicking
drop downs and all that kind of stuff
it's expensive and time-consuming and
we're looking at larger projects where
we r you know contributing to the
phenotype side of supporting genome
phenotype analysis as well the epic
relationship so that's the ohsu
partnerships and i'm going to talk about
some of the external partnerships the
epic relationship continues as you know
we're the first program to have you know
an official epic approval to use their
system their EHR for informatics
education and research we have two of
these instances up and running the
educationist this has been used for
teaching the 513 class hands on epic lay
hands on eh our lab with epic quite a
bit we've had several regular check-ins
with epic and they're pretty happy with
us as a partner of relationship and how
and and and look to us I think on
providing some kind of advice on how to
interact with academic informatics and
that's been positive we also have broad
agreement to use it as a research
instance for investigations and we're
looking to expand this into some
additional areas one thing that I know a
number of people here are very excited
about is is fire fhir that we've talked
about before and and having a version of
epic that has fire capabilities so that
so that we can do some development and a
prototyping on it again this would be
you know very limited no real patient
data constrained access and whatnot but
just having the capabilities so that you
do the prototyping I think would put us
in good stead to do some innovation
something definitely new is the IMO
collaboration we actually and this is
where you know a lot of the licensing
talk and IP and stuff comes in we have
an agreement with intelligent medical
objects which is a company that builds
terminology servers you know mapping
strings to different terminologies
ontology vocabularies all that kind of
stuff and we have a license agreement to
basically get a free version of their
system for student projects and research
and teaching etc we've got the agreement
in place it took quite a while to get in
place for the reasons that all these
things always take quite a while it's
longer than you would expect and we
should be bringing this online over over
the next year we don't actually have the
system up and in place yet I imo has
agreed to provide some training on this
so look for training or session maybe
one of these IDL talks to pop up on the
calendar where and okay the you know
this is how would you you would use this
terminology server in your projects and
imo agree to provide that once we get
the system in place by doing that a time
okay so challenges I mentioned some
challenges not just IMO but lots of
things take longer in the preparation
than you would expect very few things go
fast in terms of making arrangements
there's investment in time and effort in
in things and you have to sort of figure
out what the expected value is going to
be that because it'd be easy to spin
your wheels and a lot of things that
don't actually get realized I think we
were talking to IMO for a better part of
two years to get that agreement in place
to get to get the system for the
beginning of what we talked about it to
you know to now when we have a license
agreement signed by both parties not all
opportunities can be realizing that's
fine
that's sort of just part of business in
the real world just like not all grant
proposals get funded but you don't want
to write a whole bunch of grant
proposals that you know are you're not
going to get funded because it's a waste
of time you don't want to be involved in
a lot of business negotiations and
relationship building if it's not going
to go anywhere that said you have to
make the investment because you don't
you don't know for sure right we did a
couple of things it took a significant
amount of time that didn't immediately
realize a project or something what we
wanted to do we were part of the IBM
epic Department of Defense proposal as
you know I'd be on that wasn't selected
nobody's fault it's just the way it goes
we had developed quite a detailed
proposal to work with a startup company
and I'm not going to get into the
details of what we were going to do but
it had something to do with my research
background and machine learning and
predictive modeling and text mining and
that kind of stuff it turned out that
there are some significant restrictions
in what ohs you can do legally in terms
of intellectual property arrangements
turns out and I didn't know this until
we got into it it turns out that ohsu
being a state institution cannot sell or
give away the intellectual property
ownership you can license stuff in
perpetuity you can license stuff for
free whatever but you can't actually
give away ownership and if what you're
developing has high enough value or high
enough exposure risk the company that
you're working with they may want to own
it and so after scoping out the work and
spending quite a bit of time defining
what it would be and how we would do it
and stuff like that that their lawyers
and our lawyers came to an impasse is
that we can't do this because you need
you need to own it and we can't let give
it to you so things things happen you
learn right but it takes time and
investment to learn these things so you
don't want to have too many experiences
that result in you know finding out that
it's not going to play at the last
minute after you've been all the way
down
last thing you know sometimes it's been
difficult to get faculty and students to
use the IDL research system we've tried
to schedule some trainings and things
like that we haven't had as much buying
and participation for students as we
were hoping before and we would like I
mean maybe it's that we needed to angle
some newfangled sexy technology like
fire in front of them and they'll jump
on the bandwagon but I mean that's sad
you know these systems are you know
their shared they take time and
investment and you know we we have to
administrate access to these systems as
people need them we can't just leave
them open for you know any student to
log in and play around with and do
whatever because you may break down
break the system and bring down somebody
else's project so we need to have some
kind of some kind of you know review and
approval process to give to giving
people access just to keep it quality
resource for everybody so that implies
some minimal level of training on the
system so that you can have access for
your project but we definitely want
people to come to us with ideas of
projects that can run on this and we
would be delighted to support you in
doing research projects on these system
so key learnings I'm going to go through
this fast because I want to give people
time to ask questions partnerships are
built on relationships these take time
you want to invest that time in for the
long term and I think that's really born
out with our relationships with with all
of our partners now I mean a lot all of
our ongoing partnerships are becoming
long-term partnerships prioritization
and balance are essential you can't do
everything and how do you do develop new
opportunities at the same time that
you're actually working on the ones that
you've already committed to bringing in
commercial funding is difficult getting
people to sign a check and send it to
you that is difficult oddly enough
getting valuing kind getting licensing
for systems so that you can use them
that's not nearly as difficult so we
need to look at different ways and I
have this on the next slide about how to
collaborate with commercial entities
they think the original three years ago
I dl idea that they were going to sign
us checks and things like that to do
good work the issue hasn't bend it and
doesn't people don't believe that we do
good work or that we don't have value to
deliver to them it's just been the
Devils in all the nitty-gritty details
and that's been kind of difficult sort
of transfer of resources and kind and
things like that has been much easier
definitely some of our best
non-traditional partners are close by
kcb I k-ci and I can't say this too many
times you know agility scholarship
delivering value to the customer need to
coexist and you need to find a way to
make those things synergistic so what
are the goals for the next coming year
we were strategic planning process is
underway right now our primary goals are
number one deliver on our current
existing partnerships right both
internal and external second thing focus
on the current or future additional
partnerships we've been talking with you
know Tim from oak tree other people from
cid and whatever there is a lot of
opportunity like i said in the beginning
and a lot of need for bringing in sort
of rigorous informatics into the real
world because with academic rigor comes
you know confidence in belief and the
ability to make information actionable
it's way too easy to say i don't believe
that data and just dismiss it then it's
not actual because you don't have the
authority and wait if you will of the
data behind provide informatics
leadership at ohsu data data science
initiative all these things are getting
more and more important and we're
providing a certain input into those
things and I think that input has been
solicited and welcome which is really
great increase involvement with
important national Big Data initiatives
I think we need to look at aligning the
university with some of these things
more more and more and look at what's
appropriate role for the IDL to play in
that like I was saying before find new
ways to involve industry that you know
new kinds of new kinds of arrangements
that we haven't tried before publish
more always good not good enough all by
itself but definitely more we've got
lots of stuff that we've talked about
that we need to get down on paper and
get out there so the bigger world knows
about and continue to increase student
faculty engagement with the resources of
the IDL is providing and make them aware
of these opportunities so they can run
with them think that's the last lie so
I've saved about 12 minutes for
questions and if I don't know the answer
I'll point you to someone on my team who
does because most of them are here and
this is not a one-man show we were
talking about this earlier i'm sort of
the Tillerman i don't do all this stuff
i try to lead and direct people but
there's a whole team of people who are
doing the bulk of the real hands-on work
and so you know i thank them for all
their contributions here and they know
who they are sitting here in the front
mostly anyway yeah all the way you're
talking important so I just wanted to
point out then why we're doing this
research and we were looking at
cardiology what happened and when we
tried to look at implementing this
through epic and the validation of the
data and what we found out at the
differences between what we were doing
in chart review at what was being done
automatic was it developed a whole new
initiative in epi and across the
internal medicine and family medicine
and not cartridges cardiology of
developing a documentation review and
then developing a smart forum in which
the standardization of this data now
goes across these different departments
cardiology only sees heart failure
patients when they're in trouble they're
mainly managed by family medicine and
internal medicine then when they get to
the tertiary quant married issues such
as heart transplant and bad then we
start seeing them so by having these
data points available within these
departments it can happily actually
improve patient care and lessen improve
their life long life without going to
the transplant arena if these standards
are met so that's one thing that's
happened from this and and then the
other thing is how to visualize this an
EpiPen from this came a relationship
with CID that we didn't have before they
were clear over there and we despised
them and we were over here and now we
have that because of this project a much
better relationship with them and we
after you haven't at the analyst now on
our payroll that actually reports to me
which is a whole new way of doing things
so when you get into these projects for
us it stimulated a lot of other
innovation in other areas that wouldn't
have happened had we not gone down this
road and particularly dealing with how
to validate the the data and finding out
a lot of it was in text and instead of a
35-percent ldf it was 35 to 40 or 45 to
47 etc it wasn't a strict data point and
then finding out how to get that data
started these other initiatives and
improved our collaboration with epic
those folks on on this team yeah and I
think that really points out how this is
sort of an inner iterative synergistic
process right where the data gives you
you know information in order to turn
that into knowledge and make decisions
and those decisions might be you know
have larger ramifications that may for
example change your clinical workflow
and how you collect data and then you
may have to come up with new measures or
revise your measures in order to keep
consistent with that and so on and so
forth new opportunities get identified
but you know that the data I think and
and and validated analytics of that data
is sort of the bedrock on which you can
build some of these other
initiatives and some of these other of
actions because you can show that
they're necessary and you can show what
the gap is between what you need and
where you are so thanks for that
somebody else so I noticed that you put
up on one of the slides that fire is
coming and fhir and I guess I'm curious
because we have some internal discussion
going on right now for use of our
mammography screening decision aid and
we need a platform to go from the ipad
application to the EHR and that's one
that I know can do that so is that how
is that like six months here well so one
of that I can't give you a timeline yet
I know that and maybe bill can speak to
this because Jim Morrison has taken the
lead on bringing this over one of the
things that we need to do with our this
is being streamed but if everybody from
epic is watching we want to talk to you
about getting next version of your
system in the lab to run locally that
would implement fire so I mean one of
the things about the about the lab and
the lab versions of epic is it's really
for you know prototyping and that kind
of thing no live patient data no
clinical stuff so so you'd be able to
prototype it with this when we get it in
and you'll be able to work out what the
right way of doing it with epics fire is
if you want to then push it up to you
know ohs use real live health system
then you know you'd have to go talk to
itg and you can show them the prototype
but you know that's the that's the half
way will walk with you anybody else is
the epic instance populated with
simulated data there's a little bit it
comes from the master train and there's
some you know silly patients Bugs Bunny
you know kilgore trout you know that
kind of thing made up not a lot it's
it's you know if there were but it's
easy to add data if somebody wants to
enter it so if you had for example I
usability study where you know you had
data it could be put in but it doesn't
have a significant amount of data and it
it certainly doesn't have like like
long-term telemetry gay there that kind
of thing although again some of that's
available you know Jeff Gould and Vishnu
'he's ICU cases and stuff could be
loaded into it fairly easily if somebody
had a use for it wanted to say something
them so it just depends on what what the
purpose is if the data exists if the not
if fake patient data exists you know
there's this thing called teleport or
what do they change the name but there's
a way to teleport and data into the EHR
we could use that but if the data
doesn't exist then you have to make it
up yourself and then employ them
our community developed standards or
help this process helped develop
community standards in any other project
so we haven't been too much involved in
development of standards although that
corresponds with some of the interest of
national initiatives that I mentioned
where I mean I appreciate your input on
what would be really important and you
know bang for the buck kind of thing you
know I am oh as a proprietary
terminology server but it maps to open
standard terminologies so you know I
would hope that people that are using it
with leverage would leverage that more
than anything as far as the bio library
project again if this is a pilot project
to demonstrate value and also you know
learn and so the bio library has an
annotation schema as it is and you know
the initial project is to map to that
but you know the text mining group is
you know schema agnostic is in a matter
of fact we would appreciate you know I'm
theological input on and in a better
schemas to map things to now getting
people to use that compared to what
they're using now is a different
challenge but we're certainly open to
that one of the problems in doing
anything like this is that the extracted
values ideally really are mapped to some
sort of terminology all the time it's
not just freeform values of this or that
but not every situation has you know a
well well managed terminology to map too
so we're certainly open to that and you
know would you know appreciate you guys
talking with us with our customers about
what maybe what direction maybe that
should go but right now it's just a
pilot they have you know a big database
that has a bunch of drop-down lists and
where you know as a pilot talking
map the extracted feels to what they've
gotten their drop down so it's you know
readily import but there's no reason why
it has to stay that way what you know
one of the of the things we've done I
think probably the one that's had the
less uptake than we thought it might has
been the epic research inst I think so
too what what why what might we do it
seems like a real fertile ground
especially in this day and age where one
by one the old homegrown EHR systems are
falling by the wayside and really the
future of research about EHRs is on
platforms like epic what what might we
do to entice students faculty others to
do more with us yeah we've been thinking
about that I mean I think that that
bringing up you know the sexy new
technology is one thing another thing
that we can do you know the leading edge
epic technology stuff is being newly
integrated but another thing I think is
is you know steering students more
towards you know simulation and data
analytics and all that now I mean it's a
different issue the weather whether the
because of the lack of large-scale
simulated data is a different issue
whether epic you know the rapid research
instances even the appropriate thing for
for data analytics but certainly
anything that has to do with usability
or workflow or or you know data
interfaces or you know visualization or
anything like that has a significant
epic component a lot of you know what we
talked about even even when we're
talking about with the night
cardiovascular institute is you know
what's what's the future of getting this
back into the EHR and making it usable
on the clinician desktop from that point
of view now now that's sad there's a lot
that is important that you can do with
information that doesn't necessarily
have to be an epic but certainly one
conduit to get the information in front
of the caregiver when they're seeing the
patient is an important thing and I
think that the
we steer students in to doing projects
and research and then that direction the
more they want to use that it won't more
than want to use the research system to
do those kind of things so some of its I
think on us to steer our students in
those necessary directions that we we
know have companies last question we're
right at the hour so thank you for your
time and attention